with the xc90 Volvo has launched a new
era the second generation of the
successful high-end SUV is the first
vehicle in Volos new scalable product
architecture which is conceived as the
basis for many future models that offers
advantages both in weight and design and
for development and production the xc90
comes with five or seven seats our car
test amanta says it's not easy to put
dynamic suspension in a car that weighs
more than 2 tons like the xc90 but the
Swedish company has done a good job of
it assess with no oversteering or under
steering the car responds to your
steering better than in some compacts
montes is testing the d5 version with
its 165 kilowatt diesel engine and
eight-speed automatic transmission the
car shoots from 0 to 100 and 7.8 seconds
volvo says its average fuel consumption
is five point eight liters per 100
kilometers the diesel engines of the new
dr e engine family all fulfill the Euro
6 e mission norm annoyed version of the
new xc90 has a four-cylinder engine he
says the 2-liter diesel engine in the d5
provides enough power and the car
accelerates well the motto says there
are situations when he wishes it was a
bit more brawny mia child by llegan
height filet
a new design feature is the t-shaped
daytime running lights and in the new
generation the front axle has moved
further forward extending the wheelbase
thereby increasing passenger space and
enhancing driving stability the long
hood underscores the SUV's elegance the
new model makes a markedly more dynamic
impression that also goes for the side
and rear view the interior design has
been revamped to the arc our tester says
all Volvo's used to have a free-standing
central console here that's been
replaced by a 9 inch touchscreen that
controls the whole multimedia system
including the GPS navigation the radio
the telephone and many vehicle functions
another highlight in the interior is the
completely digital instrument panel the
driver can select a color to fit his
personal taste
the heating and air-conditioning are
controlled through the large central
display as well state-of-the-art
infrared technology lets the monitor
respond even before the driver actually
touches it the rear seats have their own
climate zones the xc90 also has a
completely new run off road protection
designed to protect passengers if the
car skids off the road a lumbar support
folds passengers in their seats and is
also designed to prevent back injuries
but we're going off-road intentionally
Montes considers the air suspension a
worthwhile investment for anyone who
wants to take the xc90 into unpaved
terrain switching the drive mode to
off-road raises the undercarriage for
increased ground clearance and also
alters the engine setting but Montes
cautions against regarding the xc90 as a
true off-road vehicle it has no
differential locks or off-road gear
reduction
then on the plus side when the forest
closes in the driver can take recourse
to a system that was actually designed
for parking and leaving parking spaces
the bird's-eye view camera for little
cameras around the car generate a
360-degree all-round view so when your
off road you can see and drive around
trees branches and rocks one of Volvo's
primary Development Goals is safer
driving and so the Swedes have pushed
forward their City safety accident
avoidance system it starts automatically
date or night when you reach 4
kilometers an hour recognising vehicles
cyclists pedestrians and obstacles that
makes it one of the most advanced
systems currently available
my father Marta sums up the new volvo
xc90 is a great car with great equipment
and great safety features but he still
thinks the ancient could have a little
more potency the more TOA dim fears or
does lets the bisschen fifth
you